all right last week i interviewed uh
vincent racinello
virologist from columbia university and
he said it does make some sense that
countries are starting to roll back
covet guidelines and restrictions
when you look at the uk
when you look at israel when you look at
other countries it makes some sense
because as this omicron wave goes down
it does seem like omicron is
significantly less deadly doesn't mean
everybody has only a cold but
there are some reports that say the
omicron death rate is 0.2 percent that
would put it at basically flu which is
0.15
vaccines widely available
very good at preventing serious illness
and death
omicron tailored vaccine coming in a few
months
if not after this wave then when is sort
of the question that is increasingly
being asked of course bearing in mind
some people are going to need to be
careful for a long time because of
specific health situations denmark is
now
going back to normal
denmark will end most coveted
restrictions and quote welcome the life
we knew before
denmark prime minister metta
frederickson announced yesterday that
denmark will throw out most coveted
pandemic restrictions that it placed
including masks
restrictions currently in place are for
the public to wear mask on public
transit in restaurants shops health care
facilities and retirement homes however
following the february 1 change of
restrictions which is tuesday
masks will only be required in hospitals
health care facilities and elderly homes
we say goodbye to the restrictions and
welcome the life we knew before
frederickson said as of february 1st
denmark will be open
according to health minister magnus
henneke
denmark's recent cases of covid were
more than 46 000 daily on average
however only 40 people are in hospital
intensive care units
we continue with a strong epidemic
surveillance then we can react quickly
if necessary despite lift of
restrictions fredrickson warned there
could be a rise in infections which may
lead to a fourth vaccination shot being
necessary which other countries have
found doesn't actually make sense
so
there are certainly controversies here
but this is a question many countries
are going to be faced with i don't
pretend to know the answer
one aspect of this that many uh doctors
are pointing to is
if not after this wave then when because
if this wave moves us to the endemic
phase where it takes on more of a
flu-like seasonal trajectory
with a lower death rate this
secondary omicron variant that now is
being looked at which may be even more
contagious but even milder although we
don't yet know for sure would push us
even closer to flu
cold
what do you wait for is the question and
it's not for me about are we now at no
risk
it's what milestone would we be waiting
for if indeed that's the trajectory so
i'm not pretending to know what needs to
happen
but i am asking
what would be the milestones if not in
another six weeks as
the cases continue to decline rapidly if
they do in in many states massachusetts
for example cases are already down more
than 50 and declining very rapidly
nationally they're declining a little
less quickly
globally they're basically flat right
now globally we're now at the peak
rather than beyond it so
more and more countries going in this
direction doesn't seem the us is close
to it i think masks on planes in public
transit will be around for a while but
there may be changes coming i'm curious
to hear from you what direction you
think it needs to go you can find me on
twitter at dpakman and we'll be back
right after this short break science has
shown us that lowering your body
temperature at night helps you sleep i
can't sleep in a hot room that's why i
love our sponsor chilly sleep which
makes customizable climate controlled
sleep solutions to sleep better their
flagship products are the uhler sleep
system and the cube sleep system which
is what i have both are hydro powered
temperature controlled luxury mattress
pads you can make them as cold as 55
degrees fahrenheit if you wanted you
could go as hot as 115 degrees
i like the cooler option i keep mine at
60 degrees and it gives me a great cool
night of sleep no feeling hot no more
sweating i'm falling asleep faster and
it pairs perfectly with chili sleeps
weighted chili blanket which keeps you
cold on top too and for a limited time
chili sleep has a special offer just for
my audience go to chilisleep.com
pacman to learn about the exclusive
discount the link is down below